as planned aaron will transform into the
attack titan and eat willie tiber
thinking that he's the warhammer titan
however soon after lara tyber will
reveal her identity as the true holder
of the warhammer titan catching aaron
off guard and this version of the story
killing him before mikasa can arrive
what happens after that
[Music]
this is where things start to play out
differently than in the anime with aaron
dead the scouts lose their confidence
getting killed easily one by one mikasa
goes berserk and tries to kill the
warhammer titan by targeting its nape as
that's where she thinks the control
center is however the warhammer titan
possesses unique abilities allowing it
to shift its control center to a crystal
casing similar to the female titans the
only difference is that the user of the
warhammer is capable of controlling the
titan from the crystal whereas the user
of the female titan is unable to do that
normally mikasa would have figured out
why the warhammer titan was still
functioning despite her fatal attacks
but the effect of aaron's death on her
wouldn't allow her to think straight
levi ackerman would then arrive and
realize the gravity of the situation he
would also figure out the warhammer
secret unfortunately the scouts would be
unable to do anything to laura tiber as
the only thing capable of breaking the
crystal is the jaws of the jaw titan
what's more without aaron they only have
the colossal titan who was acting as a
distraction on the decks moving forward
the jaw titan will arrive and the scouts
will be unable to use him in breaking
the crystal as we saw in the anime zeke
will also arrive and being the cunning
man he is he would side with marley
knowing that it would be useless to
betray them right now considering the
founding titan is lost and his brother
is dead the arrival of the two titans
will not stop the scouts and they will
fight back levi and mikasa will
especially do considerable damage to
both the titans however seeing the
massive loss they've taken following the
loss of aaron levi will command the
scouts to fall back and probably knock
mikasa out as she would definitely try
to do something rational rage the scouts
would make an attempt in escaping using
the marley airships the ones we saw in
the anime on the ride back home they
will realize just how big of a loss
they've suffered from the battle aaron's
death has not only lowered the attack
power of the people of the island but
also greatly lowered the morale as well
what's more witnessing sasha's death at
the hands of gabby will further push the
scouts down taking away their hopes and
dreams however they aren't the only ones
that have been suffering from a major
loss during the war against the mid-east
allied forces the marlenes realize that
they won't be able to depend on the
power of the titans for much longer for
them obtaining the founding titan was
crucial due to the unique abilities it
possesses especially the rumbling the
rumbling can only be used by the
founding titan and is a disastrous event
that results in the titans from the
walls destroying humanity marlene's
realized that the current technology
they possess is not enough to tackle
thousands of colossal titans marching
down on them the ability alone is what
was keeping the people of the island
safe from our lands nevertheless number
lanes are also in trouble as killing the
founding titan means it will be reborn
in an aldean child and the child could
be anywhere around the world it's
exactly for this reason that theo
maggoth wanted to capture aaron alive
instead of killing him now back home the
people of the island are shocked to the
core and extremely scared they had great
faith in aaron and the founding titan
thinking that he could save the island
once and for all unfortunately all they
are left with now is armin and his
colossal titan although the colossal
titan itself is quite strong armin isn't
as experienced as aaron or bertolt the
previous holder of the colossal type
therefore he won't be able to do much
against marley on his own this
realization was enough to spread panic
and chaos throughout the island of
paradise and at the same time give hope
to them our lands as they don't have to
worry about the rumbling anymore now
that the island forces have
significantly decreased marley decides
to launch a surprise attack before the
devils of the island come up with a
solution and to plan to counter-attack
although the loss of aaron yeager and
the founding titan did [ __ ] paradise
they still have a few tricks up their
sleeve which might help them in fighting
back and possibly saving their homeland
furthermore unlike in the anime paradise
and the scouts are now expecting marley
to counter-attack soon and have prepared
accordingly zeke yeager is well aware of
the strength that paradise possesses
even without his and aaron's help
however he will not reveal anything to
marley considering how it will
jeopardize his position there and the
fact that he might get killed for
betraying them zeke had to be extremely
cautious to reach the point he has and
will not sacrifice at all for paradise
what's more the war against paradise
somewhat aligns with his plan to putting
an end to the subjects of ymir meaning
he'll manipulate marlene forces to get
what he wants
now as paradise only has one of the nine
titans on their side the island will
depend on anti-titan traps similar to
the ones they used to capture the female
titan and will lay them down in
strategic locations hanji will work with
a team of engineers to develop more
thunderspheres to effectively tackle the
titans
now as the battle begins the scouts have
considerably strengthened their defenses
and are well prepared shocking them our
lands the biggest mistake marley could
make was thinking that paradise was
nothing without the founding titan and
they were paying hard for
underestimating them artman would be
used as bait to lure porko out and to
isolate him considering the amount of
damage he did on the ports of marley and
what he is capable of doing with the
colossal titan the jaw titan will try to
take him down with his incredible speed
however little is he aware of the
anti-titan traps armin will succeed in
isolating porco and then with the help
of the scouts they will take porco out
of the titan's nape gene will be
injected with the titan serum and he
will eat porco becoming the next jaw
titan now with two titan shifters on
their side and experienced soldiers like
levi and mikasa they will push back
marley forcing them to retreat even
though the scouts prepared as best they
could for marley's attack they still
took a lot of damage due to the lack of
power and experienced titans now however
with the jaw titan on their side they
have a better chance of fighting back as
their next move island leaders would
suggest training gene as the jaw titan
and also to use his powerful jaws to
break annie's crystal armin would of
course protest against this idea but he
would eventually realize that it's the
only thing they can do the best
candidate for the female titan would of
course be mikasa ackerman considering
her incredible physical abilities and
strength however being an ackerman she
is best suited to remain as a human and
fight with the odm gear therefore hanji
would most likely become the next female
titan due to her immense knowledge and
curiosity about them hanji would also be
able to master the abilities unique to
the female titan in no time considering
the amount of damage they dealt to
paradise marley will plan a combined
attack with other countries in order to
finish them off once and for all the
preparations for that were made in the
festival in liberio when aaron attacked
the warhammer titan willy typer used
that opportunity to strategically
exhibit aldians as innocent souls
whereas the aldians on paradise were
displayed as the real devils and the
only problem that the other nations
should worry about therefore seeing the
damage that marley took from paradise
despite not having the founding titan
the nations will cooperate in finally
putting an end to the island devils
meaning that paradise is in grave danger
unless they come up with a good enough
strategy
fortunately they did take some
precautions with the help of zeke yeager
back when he was on their side two years
before the attack on liberio zeke had
set up a meeting with the only ally of
paradise hizuru the meeting proved to be
quite beneficial for both parties
kiyomiya zumabito the representative of
hizuru was offered a business
opportunity to rebuild their industry
with the help of the odm gear and the
iceberg stone needed his fuel in return
his uber would help in building the
infrastructure of paradise and helping
them strengthen their military forces so
they don't depend solely on the power of
the rumbling itself with aaron gone
paradise needs the help of his zuru in
building the new weapons now more than
ever fortunately the azumabitos are
quite greedy and wouldn't let anyone
take down paradise due to the rich
resources it possesses what's more
kiyomi would possibly back them up in
the war due to the royal heritage of
mikasa ackerman as well therefore after
marley's initial attack paradise will
hold meetings with these immobitos and
devise a plan their win against marley
would prove to these immobiles that they
wouldn't be wasting their time and
resources on paradise armin realizes
that this won't be nearly enough and
suggests negotiating with the other
nations demonstrating their pure
intentions into the kind of life they
had before witnessing the outside world
unfortunately the image of aldians
specifically the devils of the island is
not particularly good around the world
they will be unwilling to understand
their side of the story and will side
with marley instead this would greatly
reduce the morale of the people of the
island making them feel as if it's
useless to fight against the combined
forces of the world armin despite hating
the unnecessary conflict would not give
up he and mikaso will certainly do
whatever it takes to take revenge for
aaron's death levi and the remaining
scouts will also join the final fight as
they have nothing else to lose
the final battle begins and the devils
of paradise are waiting prepared with
new weapons equipment and military
backup from hizuru they have laid more
anti-titan traps and prepared as many
thunderspheres as they possibly could
marley and the other nations launch a
combined attack and armin uses the
colossal titan as a distraction to kill
as many soldiers as he can simply by
shifting into his titan form gene will
use his agility to take down the more
experienced kart titan whereas hanji
will use the female titan with the help
of the scouts to fight enemy troops the
ackermanns will focus on the warhammer
titan and the beast titan doing
considerable damage to both the armored
titan also takes part in the war and
plays a strategic role in taking down
paradise however the thunderspheres were
specially created to handle his strong
armor dealing him considerable damage
despite paradise's desperate attempted
fighting in the war they're up against
the entire world and not having the
rumbling as a bargaining chip pushes
them into a corner the advanced
technology is being used and the
powerful anti-titan weaponry in the
possession of the enemy completely wipes
out the devils of the paradise before
going down the paradise titan shifters
and the ackermans make sure to take down
the titan shifters of marley as well
[Music]
although it felt like days had passed
during the war it actually ended pretty
quickly because of how weak the island's
forces were marley emphasizes the curse
of the aldians showing how dangerous
they can be and decides to put an end to
all aldians to which the other nations
agree for a moment it seems as though
the entire world was united but the
peace only lasts for a short period of
time eventually more wars break out and
it appears the world is going back to
fighting each other again same as they
always did check out this video where we
explained all eren's forms in attack on
titan i know you're still here come on
click it